Evan wrote in Evan says hey David when
do you think Tulsi is going to take
Elizabeth Warren down listen it's not
gonna happen okay
and I the conversate we've talked enough
about Tulsi Gabbard and other candidates
that have these sort of cults of
personality around them I don't even
really listen it if you if you literally
believe that at some point in the future
in the 2020 primary you will look at the
polls and Tulsi Gabbard will be ahead of
Elizabeth Warren I probably can't talk
you out of that belief you're probably
ideologically committed to that belief
regardless of what the facts are about
the way that this primary is going so I
don't even want to argue about that what
I want to think about is when the Tulsi
people or the yang people because I hear
this from both the tells me people in
the yang people this is an honest
question for you guys when you write in
to me and you say David the polls I
don't care what they say soon Andrew
yang will be in the lead or soon Tulsi
Gabbard will be in the lead do you
literally believe that or is it
something you say to keep up the
momentum and the energy and to try to
energize the supporters I I genuinely
want to know the answer to that because
if people really literally are sitting
around saying I don't care that Tulsi
gabbard's polling 0.8%
any day now all of a sudden she's going
to surge whether it was her threat to
boy her pre-debate threat to boycott the
debate or whether it's her performance
in a debate or whatever what is it that
you believe is going to happen in the
minds of the American people that they
will see her and say you know what
I now realize I have to support Tulsi
Gabbard what are the mechanics that you
think are going to lead to that and if
it's just something that you're saying
in order to keep people energized or
keep the energy up that's fine I would
actually respect you much more if you
wrote to me and said you know what David
I do go around online posting on YouTube
videos including yours or those of
others Tulsi is eventually going to take
over yang is eventually going to take
over the lead I don't actually
believe it I'm just being positive I
would respect that sincerely
but if you are actually waiting around
for the day that you believe is coming
where they will be in the lead of the
Democratic primary I want to figure out
exactly what it is that you're thinking
and I do think that this relates to the
very counterproductive cult of
personality around some of these
candidates that I don't really get what
the end game is and I know that
eventually when these candidates don't
win and drop out or just lose you will
then come forward and have some other
kind of motivated reasoning to explain
who screwed them or what conspiracy led
to them not winning even though they
otherwise would have and it'll be you
know endless endless motivated reasoning
along those lines I want some of you to
get in touch and say you know what David
I don't believe that they're going to
win it's just something I go around
saying because it either makes me feel
good or it makes other people feel good
I'd respect you for telling me that